presque deux mois que les plages et les
spots de surf mondialement connue du
village de lacanau n'ont pas vu un seul
baigneur
mais depuis hier l'espoir renaît pour
les élus des communes du littoral
français avec 4500 habitants à l'année
et plus de 80000 l'été le tourisme est
un enjeu primordial pour l'économie de
lacanau laurent peyrondet maire de la
ville se voit soulagé de cette annonce
et travaille d'ores et déjà sur une
demande d'autorisation auprès de la
préfète de gironde a déjà tout le plan
arrêté par écrit puisqu'on a présenté sa
déjà madame la préfète puisqu'ils ont
travaillé sur la date du 2 joueurs donc
les contacts téléphoniques vont faire
comme à mettre en place un agenda et la
façon de travailler ensemble mais c'est
de se rapprocher aussi des autres
communes de nos structures la communauté
de communes les maires du littoral nous
et l'aquitaine pour justement pour
rouvrir le plus vite possible
à nous d'apporter les garanties pour que
madame la préfète valide ce protocole
sanitaire
donc je pense que c'est parce que parce
qu'on a fournis avec le travail qui a
été fait et les moyens humains qu'on va
mobiliser sur le front de mer à lacanau
je pense que madame la préfète ira dans
notre sens mais les élus et commerçants
n'ont pas attendu les annonces du
gouvernement pour tenter de trouver une
solution
depuis plusieurs semaines certains
militent pour le concept de plage
dynamique pas de pique nique ni de
bronzette
seule la course à pied la promenade la
baignade ou encore le surf seraient
autorisées l'idée c'est quoi c'est de se
servir de la plage comme de l'ue lieu de
transit en fait c'est juste la route qui
permet de nous amener à notre père le
jeu de pouvoir aller à l'océan de
pratiquer et revenir à la maison pas de
parasols pas de serviettes de bain on
vient juste pour pratiquer notre
activité sportive et ensuite on verra ce
qui se passe dans les semaines dans
l'est dans les jours à venir pour pour
commencer à voir si en
on met les parasols on met des
serviettes et on autorise en ouvre au
plus grand nombre la plage chaque année
au mois d'août se tient l'une des
compétitions les plus prestigieuses du
monde du surf
le lacanau pro une manifestation
sportive qui n'aura probablement pas
lieu cette année
un préjudice économique sur lequel ses
organisateurs restent positifs à
situation exceptionnelle dispositif
exceptionnel et on s'adapte et on fait
on fait en fait avec la l'idée c'est de
rebondir en espérant que voilà locaux
vides dans six mois dans dix mois dans
12 mois ce sera un mauvais souvenir et
qu'on pourra enchaîner sur d'autres
événements encore plus grand encore plus
beau et surtout qu'on pourra remettre du
lien social entre tout le monde l'était
à lacanau rime surtout avec saisonniers
cette année beaucoup d'employeurs de la
ville ne prennent pas pour l'instant le
risque de signer des contrats pour la
période estivale